hey guys it's Johanna here so today's
workout we'll be focusing on your arms
and your upper body to get rid of the
bingo wings and to really tone up on
your arms as well as your upper body and
here's the good news we will not be
doing any push-ups yup no push-ups at
all so if you have a pair of light
dumbbells do grab them if not fill up
two large water bottles and use that as
your weight so let's start with a really
quick warmup let's just roll your arms
forward okay we're just warming up and
loosening up the joints
no weights and let's roll your arms back
alright
so big rolls good and you may hear few
clicks on your shoulders but that's
absolutely fine okay just keep rolling
and I'll place your hands by your
shoulders shoulder rolls alright big
shoulder rolls backwards and Big Show
the rows forward good all right
loosening up and really getting our
upper body ready and I'll just twist
side to side okay twist working on your
core as well okay good keep twisting and
now let's just get ready for the first
second
so each workout will be for 45 seconds
long with 15 seconds to rest in between
okay for the first circuit you will need
some light weights I would say between
two to three kilos each alright so the
first workout is going to be an L
squeeze to show the press so grab your
weights grab it tightly and this is how
we're gonna do it so start by lifting
your aunts just by your head okay into
an L position and what a way to do is
bring both arms together squeeze it you
should be working on your chest
as well as the shoulders opening it up
and now press it up into a shoulder
press alright so that's the first
workout and I want you to maintain this
L position throughout all right so drop
the
wait let's get ready roll your shoulders
up into an L let's go squeeze spread it
out and press it up good so keeping that
balance as well press it up and down
remember the weight or your water bottle
should be directly above your head okay
so do not swing it backwards
straight up tighten your core and really
keep your body upright do not arch your
lower back good squeeze it nice and
controlled so this is actually a
low-impact workout focusing on your
upper bodies and I want you to really
focus on every movement good press it up
slow it down do not drop your arms keep
it up one more press and back down all
right do you feel the work on your
shoulders and do all your arms give it a
job all right the second workout is
going to be focusing on your back
muscles as well as your upper back so
the bad part of your shoulders as well
so it's going to be a dumbbell row with
a fly okay so row push elbows back
spread it fly and squeeze and push your
elbows back and slightly lean forward
okay squeeze it spread it up pull your
elbows backwards at all times and keep a
slight bent on your elbows good squeeze
your mid-back and feel the work on the
back part of your shoulders as well as
your upper back keep going
very nice
one more last one spread it squeeze and
good okay the next workout will be
focusing on your triceps as well as your
biceps so bring the weights close your
body with the elbows pointed back what
are we to do is start with a tricep
kickback and then curl it up to work on
your bicep okay so kick it back to work
in your triceps and curl it up good
again leaning your body forward and do
not swing your upper arms all the
movement should be coming from your full
arms keep your back and curl it up good
as you kick it back control it down and
curl it up very nice so working your
triceps down and working on your biceps
keep going do the burn on your arms push
it back curl it up and just pinch
forward slightly good thing control
break the movement down okay so tricep
kickback down bicep curl and back it
down alright very good
and the final move it's going to
incorporate a little bit of cardio
weight that punches so you know the
usual jab and punch same thing but this
time we want to do it with weights to
add that little bit more challenge so
punch punch punch and punch okay this is
not a fast movement okay
and really work on twisting your hips
work on using the strength from your
shoulders as well as your hips to punch
forward aim at one point okay nice keep
going I can feel the burn on my
shoulders and you should too
why'd you forward laughter right and
remember to pivot on your toes ten more
seconds
do not stop right now this is your final
workout for this circuit and we want to
repeat the entire workout once more all
right
good shot 15 seconds rest okay
so the first workout is going to be an L
squeeze two
shoulda press stop in a white hell
position okay maintaining this position
at all times
let's go squeeze it in push it up good
remember to keep your body upright
do you not arch and up give it control
squeeze and up nice working on your
chest and working on your shoulders as
well okay bring your elbows close
together and out good job
whoo give me at least three more okay up
down squeeze up last one more squeeze it
and up okay now let's focus on our back
as well as our upper back okay so hinge
forward slightly from your waist
remember to keep your elbows close to
your body point it back let's start with
a row squeeze it and then spread it
apart okay into a reverse fly squeeze
very good down and up so it's two
movements into one workout
and remember to keep your knees soft
okay don't lock your knees squeeze and
spread it out good let me know what with
your using at home right now okay out
point your elbows squeeze it out last
one more up and out okay very very good
working on our arms triceps as well as
our biceps all right okay again hinge
forward keep your elbows bent slightly
let's start with a tricep kickback
remember to always keep your elbows
pointed back keep your back control it
down curl it up back down back and down
very good so remember the movement
should be coming from your forearms and
engage your triceps and your biceps okay
do not just swing it okay and gauge it
up control curl and back it down push
your back curl it up very good squeeze
at the top okay for one count curl it up
squeeze it one count get curl it up nice
whole lower it down and up two more last
one more
and back up all right final workout okay
wait the punches and you will get a
short rest all right
all energy are up okay hold the weights
let's go left leg forward right leg back
let's go left right pivot on your toes
twist work your hips twist and punch
forward if this is too much for you you
can drop the weight okay keep going
punch it good nice
remember do not drop your shoulders keep
your shoulders at your eye level
punch it forward keep going you're
almost there okay last 15 seconds and
remember to breathe out last five more
seconds
that's one more ah and just drop the
weight all right very very well done
that was the end of your first circuit
okay take a shot one minute break and we
want to continue with the second second
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for the Second Circuit we'll be working
on our map so grab your mat okay the
first workout is going to be an inch
worms to Pike press so so this is a
really great upper-body workout for your
shoulders and to really define your arms
let's go start I want to inch forward
just to the middle with your butt
pointed up give me three Pike presses so
head it down first and then slowly inch
back up all right again down remember
don't go too far I want your butt to be
sticking in the air three Pike presses
head it down push your elbows out and
slowly inch back up good if you can keep
your neck straight
let's repeat it to the middle of a mat
pike presses one two three you should
through the work on your shoulders and
come back up
okay very very good job okay second
workout let's lie down onto your belly
you can choose to use a weight if you
want you okay it's going to be Superman
squeeze to plank
so grab one weight hold it squeeze it
release it and push up to a plank back
down hold the weight squeeze release
push up into a plank so again this is a
really good workout for your traps as
well as your shooters squeeze release
push up into a plank lower yourself down
pull and squeeze
remember to slowly lower yourself down
and slowly push yourself up do not kill
yourself off the mat push up slow it
down one last squeeze squeeze release
and up okay very very good job next it's
going to be a dwarf in plank so this
time we want to start on our forum okay
so get down some of you might have done
this workout before start in a plank
position push yourself forward Pike your
butt up and move yourself forward chin
over your hands pick it back up and
repeat it okay this is a really good
tricep workout good push it forward and
also to strengthen your core really Pike
about up
feel the stretch on your back here let's
go forward and push up very good
so suck your belly in maintain a solid
drink position forward and I get up stay
on your toes
alright good forward nice and controlled
and very good okay the final move so all
the movements will be really slow side
plank extension again choose your option
if you want to grab a weight you can
what are ways to do is cut in a side
plank position grab the weight extend it
out drop it back down
tap it extend it up okay so maintaining
this side plank position was
strengthened you're on your core as well
as it will work on your balance so find
that balance and bring it up if this is
too much you can start on your knees
so tap it down bring it up let's work on
one side to begin with and on the second
round we will change to the other side
nice and controlled good keeping your
hips high do not dip your hipa cakes
keep a hips high squeeze and up very
very good okay drop the weights let's
get back up into inch one two Pike press
stop at the edge of your mat ready let's
go inch forward right through the middle
spread it elbows one two
and three heads down okay inch back
stand tall
let's go back down again the middle one
- nice
three if this is too much you can stay
closer to the mat let's go go further
take your butt up one two three back up
give me one more okay so inch solid pipe
press one two three and slowly come back
okay now let's get down onto the mat
choose your option okay with or without
anyways you just need a very light
weight okay so grab it squeeze it
leave your toes off the floor drop it
now push yourself up into a plank good
up squeeze and back down remember don't
pull yourself up okay
this is wrong solid plank back down to
really use the strength from your upper
body as well as your core press it up
back down control squeeze extend down
and press up good once more
going back down well this is a love-hate
relationship oh it really burns my
shoulders and my upper back up alright
good job okay dwarf in play all right so
your aim is to extend all the way
forward and pike all the way up so let's
get down into a plank position chin over
your arm pack it all the way up point
your elbows back over nice and
controlled and pipe it up stretch feel
the stretch on your back pack it up whoo
do the work on your triceps
do not spread it on too far apart okay
keep them close together with the elbows
pointed back very good
and just pace your breathing nice it's
also a lot of work on your core extend
up push it up and up
all right okay one loves work out side
plank extension so let's work on your
right side
all right the opposite side lie down
start in a side plank position
get up all right extend it up
tap it down and extend one fluid
movement and don't remember to engage
your core keep your hips up tap it down
and up tap and straight up
point it up very good if you're shaking
that is absolutely fine that is your
muscles working together good you are
strong last ten seconds and this is the
end of your circuit balance home I gotta
open lost my balance there and done okay
very very very well done that was the
end of your second circuit okay so I
just want you to roll your shoulders
stretch it out a little bit all right
cross your arms over stretch your
shoulders out on your right side
and now change swing it left side and
now just link your fingers together and
just stretch and look up and breathe to
bring a heart rate back it down alright
very very well done that is the end of
your upper body workout to tone your
arms as well as your shooters so we're
using both weights as well as your own
body as resistance to really strengthen
your upper body as well as to tone the
muscles okay do this workout regularly
do it on every alternate days to give
you further arms to get rid of the bingo
wings and it will also work on your
chest as well as your back if you
enjoyed this video remember to give this
video a thumbs up check out my other
workout videos strength training heat
workouts as well as healthy recipes on
my youtube channel and I will see you in
my next workout stay safe